沒開始
好 不好意思 不好意思
我剛才還以為我開始了
各位加個一 加個一
剛剛自言自語了五分鐘
好 各位有聽到聲音加個一啊
有聽到聲音加個一
我剛才還以為我開始了 你知道嗎
結果我原來我還沒開始
好好好
來來來來來來來
這個 我們一開始呢
先請各位加一下QR Code啦
我們今天呢會講這個儲置股
講儲置股 講注意股
呃 其實就重點講儲置股
那我們還會講一下00403A
喔 還會講00403A
好 那一開始 欸 各位加一下QRQ
這是PP的九折優惠券
喔 九折優惠券喔 這個在直播的時候才會開放啦
各位呢 記得掃一下
喔 九折優惠券
好 我們待會呢 這個直播內容很精彩啊
喔 會跟各位講
然後呢
我们的全球小哥讨论群
各位有什么问题都可以进来讨论
各位记得
那个半夜会有诈骗
他会模仿我
他会把大头贴
再改成我的样子
连蓝勾勾都会披上去
然后叫你说我们的群要灭了
我们群要换另外一个群
各位记得那一定是诈骗
半夜我在睡觉
不会叫你半夜在那边换群
那你假如是被骗进去的
我勸你還是不要玩股票好了
不要投資股票好了
因為你連這個都會被騙
那玩股票很恐怖 很危險
很危險的
好 那歡迎各位先加一下這個討論群
先加一下這個討論群
先加討論群
我們來看一下 我剛剛以為我開始了
現在加討論群
討論群目前是4523
那待會數字就會上升
我待會再看數字可以升到多少
好 那這個
講這之前呢 我們先來講一檔股票
今天呢 我們先來講一檔股票
叫00403A
那00403A 各位看一下
00403A 今天是
台股成交量最大 420萬
可是今天這個 理財 反正就
籌碼貼線怎麼沒有跑出來
不知道為什麼沒有跑出來
好啦 不管啦反正00403a呢 今天我 我來找一下呃我來找一下別的地方有沒有00403A買超狀況
哎呀我知道
我用我的手機連一下
喔 我用我的手機連啊
未看先猜
00403A的
這個買超最多的分點叫做
國泰敦蘭
唉唷 他也沒出來
我看一下
以財寶的沒出來,籌碼K沒出來
我看一下那個
其他家有沒有
我先找一下其他家的
找其他家籌碼
未看先猜啦
籌碼
未看先猜今天的這個
00403A齁
今天的分點呢 買超第一名
應該是國泰盾藍
我猜是國泰盾藍
欸 果然沒錯
果然沒錯
好啦
這個有人不讓我們看就算了 沒關係啊
我剛剛隨便查一個網站
一看喔 買超第一名 國泰盾藍 每次都這樣
新光也是散戶最大的分點
第二大的分點 叫新光
所以一看就知道 國泰都佔了好幾個嘛
國泰專門吸引散戶的
那這買價10.73、10.74
看起來他們很開心啦
目前看起來是賺錢的
所以呢賺錢講話特別嗆
常常都這樣
賺錢的時候講話都很嗆
所以呢我今天講說00403A有溢價
一對人來嗆瞎你知道嗎
一對人來嗆瞎
我跟妳講有溢價妳要小心點
我們來看這個在嗆什麼
我們特別來發一個警示文
好不好 錦絲文一開始的圖片呢
我就畫一個男生的
這個圖片呢 我畫了三個版本
第一個版本畫男生
但我覺得男生畫的不好看
那第二呢 我就請他畫一個女生
身材較好的女生
結果他一畫呢 那個
胸部畫太大 失業線太深
再加上畫一個那個
失業線不要太深
就換這一個
那0403A齁 今天呢他是
市場溢價的
這個收盤價10.8
但禁止才10.23啊
你知道禁止10.23什麼意思啊
就是你假如可以在市場上認購00403A的話有一個東西呢叫做初級市场初级市场呢你可以去问你的营业员问你的营业员
你明天就可以问他说
我可以来认购00403A吗
初级市场认
那明天好像可以认
那可以认 你也可以认
但是明天认的那个
价格不一定
因为他要看当天的禁止
所以你明天认呢可能是10.1
或是10.2
明天大凡大几下蛋可能就10.1 10.2
可能是10块
你可以认10块
但是你在市场上可以卖10.8
你可以去农券放空锁单
所以套利方法就是第一个农券放空锁单
这是比较简单的
就是农券放空锁单
然后呢去市场上认
认了之后呢两天到你的户头
两天到你的户头之后呢
你就可以做一件事啊
你就来做一件事叫现券偿还
你可以做现券偿还
這個是500張一組
500張一組就是500萬
500萬就可以套了
我會去套嗎 我會去套
我已經跟我營業員講好了
我已經跟營業員講好了 說我明天要認
那明天一定很多人去認
為什麼 因為大家都想宰笨蛋
再跟各位講一次
大家都想痛宰笨蛋
那誰是笨蛋呢
來 誰是笨蛋呢 來來來
這群人是笨蛋
這群人
我想去痛載笨蛋啦
國泰敦南 國泰台中 國泰板橋 星光 國泰桃園
這群人是笨蛋
他們都想痛載他
那怎麼痛載 很簡單啦
他只要做一件事啊
先去市場上初級市場認
初級市場認500萬
500萬就可以認
初級市場認完之後呢 做什麼事啊
初級市場認完之後呢
在這個0403A 明天可能就有融券了
呦 各位看到沒有
我才 融券出來了
今天融資10萬張
明天一定一堆龍卷
小朋友今天就可以有卷空
我看很多家都沒卷空
今天就一堆人
一堆人已經先去空了
那00403A的下場呢
會跟誰一樣? 我跟各位講
只要可以套利
他這個正價差
他這個溢價
很快就會收斂
只要可以套利
龍券空給他死當然收斂啊
你龍券空了你又不怕被嘎
對不對 你空了兩天後
兩天後那個這個 你的認的股票就來了嘛你認的股票就來了然後呢就可以幹嘛做現券償還就好
你榮券連補都不用補
我按錯了齁
來看一下
哇
按到後台
我要看這個
來
這個我們現在看這個套利齁
這邊
這裡
我看一下
怎麼樣
歷史不斷重演
老牛說得很好
小哥真好心提醒
你要跟台灣人說CP值很差
對 講CP值很差可以啦
你要買這個
你去買CP值好的嗎
你買這個幹嘛
加人家5%對不對
買一台電視加100塊就不賣了
然後買個ETF多人家5%
然後那個怎麼樣
然後很開心
很開心喔 你看喔
買台股
假設買20萬一張的台股能買啥
你可以買台積電90股啊
台積電買個90股至少沒有議價嘛
你買台積電90股也可以買啊 對不對
難道403A他買這三個月都不會漲嗎
我講的是議價 你跟我講他會不會漲
對不對 我講的議價 議價5%什麼意思
你現在買就是買台股多少
你現在買就是買台股44000點的位置
你買44000點的位置
假設三個月後漲到5萬點
你403A當然也會漲啊
當然也會漲嘛
那假如三個月後漲到4萬3000點就好了
你403A是跌的勒
你懂嗎 你的403A會變跌的
但是你買指數都是漲的啊
所以我們用邏輯理論
用邏輯理論來講股票
那別人呢用情感來回復我們
你知道嗎
呵呵呵
別人用情感來討論
我為什麼要講這些呢
我總不能跟他講說
你知道嗎 我在台股
我 我 我總不能以老賣老
你知道嗎 我吃的鹽
比你吃過的飯還鹹
我總不能講這種嘛
講這種看起來也怪怪的
對不對
那我們至少在市場上很久嘛
我們都知道說
這個這市場上
什麼事該做 什麼事不該做嘛
所以這邊也寫得很好啊
這453張一路順遂啊
繼續尻寄沒多少錢
沒多少錢
沒多少錢你可以去買別的
你可以去買他成分股
你買什麼403A啊
你懂嗎
買什麼403A啊
楊叔叔說我上次寫一篇
就被靠北了
我寫這個
這片也是被靠北
你知道嗎
美股低潤ETF也是一開始猶豫
後來沒有藍後直接噴發
欸 又來了
又來了
又開始跟你寫別的
然後說直接噴發
就是鼓勵人家買嘛
閃物沒在看禁止議價的
然後呢
還記得0098夜
議價的慘痛教訓
沒講到議價隔天禁止一直
他議價有5%嗎
他什麼時候議價5%了
我不知道他議價有5%咧
沒有咧
他假如議價5%也是會收斂啊
也不是不會收斂嘛
喔
我只能說小哥信仰價值不夠
下個月漲到20塊 關你什麼我怕一下
欸 你漲到20塊 什麼意思
漲到20塊台股是7萬點
至少
至少7萬點
至少7萬點喔
我說那台股7萬點會先來喔
你也拜託欸 對不對 你漲到20塊
這個 欸各位
你要不要去看他的成分股啊
他現在00403A的成分股
其实跟很多00981A什么种类似啊
他不是去买00981A15块钱那时候的股票
他也是去买00981A30块的时候的股票
00981A现在30块
403A现在是10块
他们未来的价差大概就是这样子
大概就是三倍
你假如是这个981A跟403A的比值
他约莫不大会变动
不大會變動
但是我跟各位講00403a呢
它之後呢會有一個很大幅的怎麼樣
很大幅的跌回來 為什麼
因為 因為它要先把這個溢價給收斂
你懂嗎
它要先把這個溢價給收斂嘛
所以呢 一堆人不懂
一堆人不懂
然後就
然後就來這邊嗆
你看00981a沒買到現在都漲到30元了
過這次就15 20元還在那義價
還在那義價
你最好15 20元就一直上去
你明天只要可以申購
我不曉得明天能不能申購啦
反正明天只要可以申購
你就看到盤中一堆龍券在那邊空
龍券在那邊拚
空了也不用回補
反正只要怎麼樣
你只要申購完兩天後還券
事情就解決了
所以呢這個義價
這溢價你真的
買超低迷 國外都難進20萬張前陣子長太兇現在一堆人不把這5%看上去你也要涨超过5%你这个5%才会
才有
你有可能
明天风子更多啦
搞不好今天溢价5%
那明天那个溢价20%
有可能啦
有可能也不一定不可能啦
只是我们都讲
这个溢价多了就是不能买
再讲一次
溢价多了就不能买
因為它存在了套利空間
你看這個又嗆了
預價為何不先假設
如果大盤繼續上漲
請問有預價問題嗎
大盤繼續上漲你不會買台子旗喔
不會買0050喔
你為什麼要買00981A呢
你為什麼一定要買這種預價5%的
大盤有可能漲了5%之後
他先修正這個預價
你懂嗎
然後後面呢 後面才漲下去
那你看一下今天
哇 今天有人貼啦
今天外資賣
外資為什麼賣
因為它可以套啊 當然賣啊
它可以套利嘛
自營商避險
自營商這個就是肇事啊
今天賣了243萬張給散戶
243萬張散戶
成分股也差太多了 這樣分析不認同
我在說預價 你要說成分股
我真的不知道要說什麼
我現在講預價
98AA都幾次預價了
起碼還把台股撐上一片天
你呢
喔 有夠強
超級強
我呢 我
我交易稅繳很多
也把台股撐上一片天
你呢
換我繳回去
我交易稅也繳很多
好啦 那
這一
我可以講
喔 這一千 這很爽啊
這個是 現賣喔
現賣 依價5%
現股賣出
很爽啊 對不對
這個
我都買折價
你買在10塊錢 恭喜你啦
喔 這個禁止呢 目前才10.23
喔 10.23喔
所以 預價5%並不滿
你明天知道 你就知道
反正呢 只要怎麼樣
只要可以
可以怎麼樣
只要可以申購
他那個預價就是會收斂
你要不要看一下009819
009819 我有空到喔 我有空到喔
009819 我空了 賺了20%吧
我要看在這裡
欸 有人賺了10幾%
10幾%
看在這邊
這一天沒空到 因為這一天沒卷
這一天 一早要卷 要一堆卷11.33 這一天溢價20%隔天收斂剩13% 再隔天整個收斂回來
就沒了
整個溢價就沒了
很快 現在市場上很有效率
農卷呢隔天暴增
那些笨農資還在買
一下子就整個收斂
好啦
中信數據及電力這個不香
你981也比較香
我們中信數據電力不香嗎
這個有人還說
小哥你一定是別的頭顧派來
抨擊981A的
我沒有要抨擊981A
我是舊式論事
我今天講的是403A
我今天沒有講981A
你今天要買981A非常歡迎
因為他至少沒有溢價這麼誇張
那我們981A
不香嗎
博通甲骨文
對不對 不香嗎
對不對
這些核心持股不香嗎
然後一定是你的403A比較香
你的403A
我們來看一下00403A成分股
來看一下成分股
你自己看
台積電 台光電 齊用 台南電 茂蓮 連電 青 金字邦 群聯
他買這些大部分 981A都有啊
你買981A就好了 你買403A
對不對
平面都差不多的東西
有人預價5%你要買
有人預價沒那麼多
你現在981預價多少
反正不會到5% 不可能5%
他現在平均他的這個折預價都不高
我來看一下
我來看一下這個00981
我來看一下現在的預價是多少
你要買00403 我建議你買00981
好不好 今天預價0.23%
0.23%而已
有人嗆我說什麼
你981A都預價很多沒有
我現在看
很少有一天預價超過1%的
很少 我現在看最近這兩個月是沒有
成本股都一樣
成本股都一樣 你就要買403
多人5%
人家買的是未稅 你買的都要含稅
你買的都要含稅在裡面
你知道嗎
人家買的股票是未稅
你買的寒稅
然後你要賣的時候
怎麼稅不見了怎麼5%不見了然後到時候再嗆說這個怎麼投信坑殺你啊投信也沒有坑殺你今天投音投信都已經發文了
說溢價不要再買了
那我今天也發文了跟你講說
溢價你還可以來套利
你可以套利喔
溢價可以套利
我們來看一下
哇今天這個發這篇文
今天這篇文流量很高
他們都講不聽了
那發這篇文也是一堆人來嗆
嗨嗆
我送錢我開心
讚
真的
真的有這種
有這種
送錢開心的
我們真的要多多鼓勵
我們真的是
這市場上就缺送錢的人
所以我給他比個讚
一堆人都知道
溢價那要繼續送錢
超好笑
申購1000張直接套利
對 沒錯
直接套利
那可是這升購
我說你明天可以升購你還可以升購
現在一價明天又漲後天又漲
這不是一價了啊
你最好現在漲明天漲然後漲超過5%
只要把蜜月期五天漲後會漲的價格局
上次第一天透過來用了
難道你要等到年底漲到20塊
你才天天喊一價
我覺得你198夜了解
這是一樣
到現在還有人在喊一價
我們用
用邏輯來講這個
然後別人呢 就用情感來回嘴
沒有啦 我跟你講 其實這些人都要想申購
我跟各位講 他們都想申購
跟我一樣 他們都想申購
他們明天都會申購 你知道嗎
但是總是要在這邊喊一下
讓笨蛋來幹嘛 讓笨蛋來買
總是要喊一下
讓我們秉持著良心路線
總之要告訴你 我明天我要申購好不好
明天有申購
我就申購
有申購我一定空爆他
我申購一千張我就空一千張
好不好
申購一千張我就空一千張
好嗎
他們會說三天後一家又一個
呵呵呵
真的
反正我不怕誤差印象
有錢人真好
起碼比90年好多了
好啦
同一字體都發文 同一字體都發文了你知道嗎
同一字體都發文了
唉
真是萌啦
好啦
這個
403A就這樣 好不好
403A各位 403A不要
去追了 好不好
預價太多
韭菜很多 好不好 韭菜超級多
韭菜呢都在
國泰
為什麼因為國泰 國泰打折
國泰打折 打二八折
一堆散物都開國泰敦然
那散物
每次常常
always幹了什麼事
幹了蠢事
閃入always幹蠢事啦 你自己看
喔 這個中訊數據一上市就幹蠢事了
對不對
一上市就幹蠢事
來來來
第一名 國泰敦蘭嘛 你看 你看 你看看 你看看
國泰敦蘭 國泰台中 國泰板橋 星光 你不覺得這幾個人很面熟嗎
有沒有 很面熟
大家都了解 對不對 大家都了解
你有沒有覺得很面熟 跟剛剛那個
00...
跟剛剛00403A買超的分點是不是很像
你有沒有覺得跟剛剛403A買超分點很像
就是喔
跟剛剛403A買超分點很像
欸!都一樣啊!分點都一樣啊!
這幾個啊!敦南台中板橋清光嘛
對不對
這跟剛剛的分點很像
呵呵呵
同一頭戲怎麼套利 同一頭戲其實很爽啦
他就盡量賣就好啦 你們這些笨蛋全部賣給你 好不好
全部賣給你
同一頭戲很爽
他還算有良心啦
他一邊賣一邊笑 然後還一邊發文
一邊賣一邊笑一邊發文
就這樣
所以各位不要去追這個喔
今天抑價5% 搞不好後面抑價
抑價那個
10% 20% 30%
好啦 他有可能
我跟你講
市場上有一檔 溢價最誇張的
我想想看 是哪一檔
喔 00887啊
00887 唉呦
唉呦 漲上來了齁
再怎麼漲上來
來吧 這一天就是溢價啊
這一天就是溢價 溢價到38塊啊
溢價到38塊 然後現在再怎麼漲上來
也沒有到38塊啊
這就是溢價追的嘛
然後這溢價追的就散戶追的啊散戶追的 你懂啊統一投資賣貴 他當然可以套利 他很爽好不好
他賣你很貴的ETF 他去買打95折的現股 你懂嗎
你買的台積電是那個原價 他買的台積電也是原價
但是他對外賣的ETF可以加5%的稅金 你懂嗎
他可以加5%賣給你啊
啊這個00887
00887這個也是溢價啊
曾經溢價後面收斂啊
你買38塊給我7.3
你再跟告訴我
中國很強啊
等到有一天中國漲到天上去
這38塊都會回來的
38塊回來會回來嗎
我是不曉得啊
但是到現在為止還是沒回來啊
你懂嗎
然後你現在00403A
現在這個價格就是台股還要再漲2000點啊
再漲2000點
不好意思
更正一下
因為夜盤
夜盤我看現在跌幾點
剛剛夜盤跌滿多的
哎呦 358
從現在開始台股大概還要再漲2300點
還要再漲2300點喔
再漲2300點
因為現在夜盤已經跌了300多點了
所以呢 從現在開始
你要先把台子旗夜盤的跌幅
而且夜盤跌幅 我跟各位講
現在夜盤很恐怖
欸 你曾幾何時看到台子旗逆價差啊
你曾幾何時看到台子旗逆價差
今天台子旗是逆價差勒
各位 你知道嗎 今天台子旗逆價差
41898加任時速縮盤
但今天台子旗呢
夜盤開盤是41704
台子期日盤的收盤是 41704
是第一次的逆價差
很久很久很久沒看到了
因為一堆股票增價差 台積電都增價差
所以我們很久很久沒看到逆價差的台子期
你很久沒看到逆價差的台子期
你現在有便宜的台子期可以買
你還要去買貴的 00403A
你是貼腳有問題嗎
台子期的成分股跟 00403A
高度相似啦 我說成分股
因為權重關係嘛 高度相似
台子棋嘛 有台光電嘛 有台積電嘛
上面也都有啊
高度相似啊 那你幹嘛不買台子棋台子棋現在還便宜賣 好不好你現在夜盤賣夜盤賣少1% 夜盤買少1%你買403A多5%
那內容不會差很多
然後你在那邊買 不知道買什麼
好 那403A就這樣
403A這個流量非常高
好啦 那我們現在先
各位先加個討論群啦
加個討論群 那我們來看處置神器
處置神器最近賺翻了
真的賺翻了啦
喔 那個
我先給各位看那個處置神器
這個處置神器的活動優惠三五折
各位先看一下
他有基礎處置策略 今天處置策略雙刀戰法
每月實戰陪跑 還有專注台灣群組
今天有優惠
那我們先來看處置神器我們的戰績
先看那個學院的戰績
學院戰績
等一下
好
儲置神器這邊賺3萬1
三黃 我也做到
4945,916,泰森三黃
這些他們都買儲置
全新我有買
全新我今天賣一些的
然後呢 三黃
大家買的差不多
因為大家都是去買那個浪子回頭的
那儲置神器很簡單啦
反正就是浪子回頭去研究一下籌碼好不好
籌碼好你就買 籌碼不好你就可以放過
就這樣而已
好啦 一個人叫我不要買
叫我不要講 因為今天儲置神器有它
特別的活動 為什麼 因為我們今天
這個
我登錄一下 LINE 一下
因為今天儲置呢 儲置神器它有一個 WEB版的畫面
因為有 WEB版的畫面呢 所以我們要講一下
好啦 講之前 我登錄之前先給各位看個東西
先給各位看個東西
來來來來
我先給各位看一下那個儲置的版本
好 這裡喔
那今天呢 今天蠻好玩的
今天是那個
一堆人他預測
一堆人預測那個
等一下我先登錄一下
預測聯發科會進組織
那我們盤中就知道說聯發科今天不會進組織
我們這個組織神器的那個
數值現在研究的非常的
非常的透徹
所以呢 聯發科我們今天盤中就知道
他不會被管
那些一堆人以為聯發科會被管
因為他們很多家都算錯了就我們家算對因為那個 我常常跟他們講說你千萬不要算錯你算錯 我賠得最多因為我已經下得最大所以我跟他講說 你不要算錯
你算錯會影響到我的交易
所以我盯得最緊啦
因為我最不希望他算錯
全世界最希望儲置神器不要算錯
那個是我
我做的是做最大的
好 那儲置神器呢
各位 明天呢 向林同閉關
閉關股 1天20分
他要一天 但這個以後呢 我們會有web版出來
web版給各位看
那裡面還有這個注意公告 組織公告 還有雙刀
就是以後的電腦版本
電腦版本 這個很好用
那我們首先來看一下
這個上次處置 上個禮拜我講一檔股票叫建測
哇這建測呢 真的是一個
呃 最慘最慘的狀況
最慘最慘的狀況 就是
我買完建測之後 結果建測遇到一個大力孔
遇到一個大力空
就是黃仁勳說
那個
以後
散熱不需要這麼多
只要用冷氣
用電風扇就好了
所以那時候呢
限建設跌停
然後呢
東元漲停
冷氣電風扇
用冷氣
冷氣不夠加電風扇
所以東元冷氣跟電風扇
表現非常好
漲停板
好啦我看一下
他意思就是說
就是說那個散熱不用兩塊板子
一塊就好了
那導致呢 我隔天立馬遇到兩根跌停
好 那我遇到跌停的時候
各位 我在這裡買了八張
你知道八張多少錢嗎
八張已經快多少錢
八張已經是三千
不是三千多萬
快四千萬了 你知道嗎
快四千萬 然後吞了這三根
那吞了這三根呢
相當於大概要賠掉一千萬
那但是呢我在隔天喔
隔天由於他的期貨沒有跌停
我判斷現股會跌停 期貨沒跌停
所以我在隔天做一件事
我拼命的去空期貨
拼命的去空期貨
好 那這個是我的期貨
我有去空大建設 空小建設
因為我知道
他現股所死
跟各位講 反正跌停只要所死的我一律賣掉
漲停只要
只要漲停的我一律去買
漲停的一律買
跌停的一律賣
這是交易的一個基本邏輯
大家都在賣你就要跟著賣
大家都在買你就要跟著買
漲停跌停基本邏輯是這樣
那
建設股票跌停所使
我大概是空建設股期啊
所以呢我用建設股期呢幫我避了點險
即便這邊呢是賠了900萬
可是建設股期呢幫我避險這邊賺了360
然後呢這個戶頭我用兩個戶頭做
這戶頭賺了140這邊又是戶頭270
所以兩個戶頭呢大概幫我撈回來600萬
所以呢我即便這邊
賠了900萬但是要幫我撈回600萬
那這900萬呢
最主要的原因呢是我賣在這一天
我賣在這一天
這裡
建測呢 我賣在這個位置
這位置
那為什麼我要賣在這個位置
齁 來來
建測呢 我賣在這一天
這裡 3650
那為什麼要賣在3650
因為我3500 我吃了一堆啊
我3500 我吃一堆 我要嚇傻
我3500 我吃一堆啊
你知道嗎 3500 我就吃一堆建測了
3650 我只是把我庫存賣掉而已
啊把庫存賣掉 當然以實現損益非常醜
齁 有沒有看到
以實現損益很醜
但是我未實現水益很漂亮啊
那時候呢 這個
我賣的 這是另外一個戶頭
另外一個3653建設
另外一個戶頭的履月水益 各位看到嗎
這邊呢 又賺了一千多
因為這邊呢 有很多成本都在三千五
那為什麼我知道 建設呢 它不會再跌下去的
有以下幾個理由
我在這邊呢 跟各位講
講幾個理由啦 講大家比較知道的
那各位呢 你假如想知道
更細節的
歡迎你去訂閱我的PP
我的PP呢其實那兩天
我講了非常多的建設
因為我們遇到了
我們買進了嘛
因為浪子揮頭買進了
那遇到了狀況
那遇到狀況
我們要想辦法轉回來
你遇到難處
遇到困局
你要想辦法把它逆轉回來
我遇到兩根跌艇
我都可以逆轉回來
都可以逆轉回來
而且呢 我的点位会抓得很准
那为什么会这样子抓
那我在PP讲的很清楚
那我在这边呢
跟各位讲几个
讲几个我观察到的东西
第一个当然是它低档爆炸量
第一个是低档爆炸量
低档爆炸量这个是非常重要的概念
低档爆炸量
第二个呢
我还会去看一下
这个建策呢
它盘中的卖单是怎样释放出来的
盘中的卖单怎样释放出来的
他卖单我发现他那种释放的时间点
看起来很像投信所以那天我特我特別的說我就猜那建策呢 肯定是投信弄出來的
肯定是投信賣的
投信賣的
好 等一下 我看一下
這個建策肯定投信賣的 我找一下
因為我前幾天呢
前幾天我上理財達安秀
那上理財達安秀呢 我還有做一張圖
但是我沒有發 我忘了發
因為那天我都在發那個
那天我都在發那個
發母親節吃的 就沒有發到
好啦 反正各位你可以去看理財達人秀那一篇
那一天我講建策講得非常長
結果講完之後隔天是漲停板
隔天漲停板
那你說我是叫閃物去買買要漲停
拜託的建策餒
又不是98又不是403那10塊
大家很好買
欸 這4000塊你要怎麼買
4000塊要怎麼買
4000塊很難買的啦 對不對
所以呢 這個
這個是這種漲停
很簡單 各位你只要記得一件事
連續跌停之後呢
連續跌停之後的爆大量
那肯定是想賣的人都賣掉
很簡單 只要想賣的人都賣掉
想買的人都買
買進來 他就會出大量
然後想賣的人 這些人走了之後
剩下留下來的都是信心堅定的
建設在那一天是不能做這個資券當充的
因為他在盤下不能資券充
盤下不能資券充
你在這天你買建設
你說我來空手套牌人
空手套牌人 我在3500買進3650賣出
不行 不行
你不能在3500買進3650賣出
除非你有庫存 像我一樣我有庫存
我有庫存我才能賣 好不好
好不好 我有库準才能賣
所以我是3500買進 我3650賣出
我先做這個隔日沖一趟
那3650即便很醜 完全不care 為什麼
因為我有那個 我有買3500塊的建設
而且呢 我還可以用期貨避險
那時候建設的期貨跟限貨差了100塊
可以用期貨避險 我還可以套出其中的利
那建設期貨跟限貨呢
在這兩天建設出關之後呢
他收斂到大概五六十塊
所以呢 我們除了解救危機以外我們還去做套利所以整個做完之後呢建設設原本從我假如都沒理他的話 都沒理他然後跟投信一樣傻傻的停損
給各位看 這就是投信賣的
那時候我就說 投信就是個笨投信
好不好 就是笨投信
他肯定是笨投信的 他就
投信會砍在這個阿呆鼓
好不好 阿呆鼓
買權政的都比他厲害
各位啊 這裡買權政都比他厲害
買全證的人都比他厲害
都在這邊大買
投信是砍在阿呆股
為什麼投信要砍在阿呆股呢
因為投信是相對績效
那什麼叫相對績效
就是我今天隔壁有建設
我有建設我就是要賣得比他早
我沒賣得比他早的話
我的績效會輸給他
那投信績效是這樣子喔
你跟老闆說
老闆我今年要求加薪
我績效20%
老闆說滾
說滾 隔壁績效50%你才28 滾
就把你趕走了
那另外呢
那個 你就跟人家 老闆不好意思
我今年這個績效不好
我今年績效-20%
然後你說加薪 加薪
你知道隔壁呢 今年績效-50%
你-20%就給你加薪
-20%加薪
所以他們是相對績效
那假如相對績效的話
那麼投信呢
他在低檔 他只會大砍
那投信呢就是一個停損哥的紅包
好不好 停損哥的紅包
投信是停損哥的紅包
我們就講停損哥的紅包又大又肥
你看這次就是很肥嘛
就是有笨投信把它賣出來
那投信只要賣出來
我在前兩天我就跟學員講
只要建設 不要跌停所使
我一定大買
所以呢給各位看
這就是大買的證據嘛
我一定大買啊 買爆它
好不好 買爆它
就這樣
這頭巾就大買
這邊
3520張
事實上不止啦
這是其中一筆而已
這其中一筆而已
那這個呢
我們用這交易
這個
真的賺蠻多的
我先截個圖好了
我先截個圖
先來截一下
這個月
這個月我這個戶頭
我這個戶頭
那這個戶頭呢
有做一些這個處置的交易
做一些處置的教育
那這個月呢
這個其實沒有很好
應該說還蠻好做的但是沒有上個月那麼好做蠻好做的沒有上個月那麼好做唯一的原因就是建設因為建設呢 讓我在浪子回頭後吃了兩個跌停
但這個我是覺得是非戰之罪
非戰之罪
好 來來來
我現在
我現在登錄一下
登錄一下
給各位看喔 因為這個要登錄
來,登錄啊,登錄我的手機
登錄完,各位呢,給各位看我手機的畫面
這是手機呢,那個
剛剛截的圖出來的
剛剛截的圖出來
那這個,最近處置才太好玩了
這我沒有學,欸
我剛剛那個學人聊天
我剛剛學人聊天,我是覺得蠻好玩的
學人聊天,我來截個圖好
因為這個學員聊天呢 這個
講話蠻好笑的
他說
來來來 給我看一下
這剛剛學員的聊天啊 我把它解讀一下 因為保護他
自從買了處置神器 我上台北高鐵沒坐位 我就買商務艙 絕對不委屈自己做自由座
非常好 這個絕對不委屈自己做自由座
太優秀了
好啦
這個給各位看我剛剛截的圖啦
這剛剛才截的
這邊呢是這個月的損益
這裡
我剛剛截的圖嘛
9點42分
5月1號到5月12號
損益了2100萬
那這個大部分呢
都是靠儲置來做
大部分靠儲置 做儲置
那這個做儲置呢 今天賣的哪些
我今天這個秘密麻麻
來來來來
給你看一下
這是我今天的筆記
因為真的
來來來來 這個是筆記
給各位看 先看一下筆記
秘密麻麻 這裡面全部都儲置的
秘密麻麻
手寫 因為太多檔了
太多檔了
我今天有賣哪些呢
6217有賣一些想不到立馬漲停
太快漲停了 你看這是不是儲存
這就是那個浪子回頭
後面變東山再起啊
各位你看一下
只是他籌碼沒有那麼好嘛
籌碼沒有那麼好但是我覺得他出怪還是有機會漲
我還是買了
浪子回頭東山再起我今天賣了一堆股票
賣了一堆股票因為這些股票很多都漲了錢頂
低檔買的今天上去賣一些
還有賣那個賣最多的
在昨天也賣了 全新
浪子回頭東山再起了嘛
對不對
好 啊這些呢
這些喔 來來來
我又再跟各位講 我買了什麼股票了
我買這幾檔股票
買了不曉得會不會被狙擊
會不會跟建測一樣 我不知道
但是呢 我可以很誠實的跟你講
我今天買了什麼股票
我上次講的建測 結果建測大跌
害我這個
這個
敗戰處理 處理了一段時間
來 今天呢我買了什麼股票
我今天買了那個月城 6405
各位
月城喔
你看一下月城 月城的籌碼還好
還好 還不算特別爛
但是我今天買的均價大概在57塊多
56 57都有買
我今天買的分點已經變成是
那個全台第一名了
我買了這一檔
那這一檔後面怎麼樣不知道
但是呢往下呢我會分批承接
我現在買了月城
我又買了川寶
川寶是五分鐘的
就今天一買就一個下影線
我還可以先賣掉一些
明天見車
明天見車被關了
好不好明天見車被關了
所以我今天買
我還有買一個我覺得籌碼沒有很好
所以我沒有買很多
就立馬獲利了
叫永勤
他籌碼真的是比較醜啦
但是因為他已經到月限了
而且呢他要出關了
所以呢我今天在第一檔呢我就買他
永勤我有買
我看一下我的筆記啊
欸打電話有沒有記起來啊
喔 反正771有買
這個太多檔了
771有買 反正來看一下
我看一下有沒有我的分點欸 有 有 有 有分點也上去了反正我的分點都上去了啦都給你看 分點都上去給你看 沒關係你也都看得出來我的損益
哈哈
都看得出來我的損益
那你看 這個
這個我買的都跟你講
不用怕 兩根跌停我都遇過了 我還怕什麼
兩根跌停都遇過 不用怕
然後呢 這個 我們什麼時候買呢
就是浪子回頭找買點
來 再給各位看
他這個軟體就很簡單
浪子回頭找買點
然後儲置回檔10%後找賣點
像我昨天我有買雍智科技
昨天我有買
今天就可以賣了 但是我還沒賣
雍智科技 儲置回檔後漲10%
東山再起
月城浪子回頭 所以我買了浪子回頭
月城我今天買了 川寶我今天買了
這月城買了 儲置後疊18%我買了
川寶這出現兩個訊號
前點我今天賣了嘛
菠蘿薇我沒有買到好可惜
不然邊菠蘿薇也是蠻甜的
東山再起
油田也東山再起了
油田東山再起
油田我好像是
我是空單回補我還沒買
空單回補還沒買
東山再起冬結
你看這幾檔
這幾檔都是最近怎麼樣
都最近呢它有
跌下來
又長上去了
所以呢
我們的秘方就是
讓紙回頭的時候會通知你
喔 這個會通知你
然後呢 之後怎麼樣
跟各位講
小秘書他們很厲害
他們之後呢
會把這個軟體呢
還用一個語音版
看一下
有語音版在哪邊
喔 在上面
我看一下 語音在哪裡
喔
唉呦
他在語音跑去哪
喔
呃
他有語音 語音跑去
反正以後呢會有一個語音通知
這邊 點一下
好
以後會有語音通知啊
來 我把這個語音通知呢給各位聽一下
所以以後呢就不用擔心了
但是呢你假如在上班要小心啊
小心開 開啟
免得那個老闆問你說
欸 什麼是浪子回頭
你可能要解釋一下
什麼是浪子回頭啦
浪子回头7711
东山再起8064
东山再起3455就这样等一下各位有听到嗎浪子回頭7711
東山再起8064
東山再起3455
以後就這樣哦會有這種語音通知
那通知完之後各位不是通知完你就買不是這樣子
你要再過濾一下好不好
再過濾一下你覺得籌碼不錯的可以買
籌碼很爛的話你的買點就後面一點
你的买点就后面一点
那假如筹码很好的话
就像我们上次跟各位讲的嘛
304上次赚很多的
筹码很好的
这个浪子回头一定买爆
那后面不知道出关之后
后面行情不知道
但我们出关那天就卖掉
好不好
各位你看我那个
那五月份的这战绩里面呢
经济也是占了一大部分
经济也让我赚很多啦
这个就是因为
他有一个浪子回头讯到一个东山再起讯
然后呢你可以
欸 我們這群喔 這群少了一個人
我們的這群
這個處置的第一群 第一群少了一個人
變499
阿民上電視的 期待為我們處置
小哥也有手帳本
好啦 但他們都聊得很開心啦
那現在因為人數太多了 所以我們又再成立另外一個社群
那現在呢 這個浪子回頭 他就有這個
欸不是 不是這樣
處置呢他現在有一個社群
那這社群目前是
目前是這邊
這邊有個社群958人在裡面
所以在裡面呢會來討論一下
這個
我在裡面也會討論
討論那個這個處置的一些交易
那我在當時賠錢我也跟他們講
這個建設賠錢就賠錢沒什麼了不起
賠錢常遇到
但是賠錢的危機處理很重要
那我建設呢 我危機處理就是
跌停的時候我空古期保護
只要一跌停所指
古期可以空的就空古期
他就是一個買賣邏輯的判斷
因為跌停所指代表明天有可能
那個法人繼續砍嘛
因為這就是笨法人好不好
這個會把他賣到跌停就笨法人
法人一直賣一直賣嘛
但是法人一直賣賣不掉
等到有一天他賣完了
他賣完了
那個沒有跌停
那就是要谈了 很简单的逻辑
好不好 就这样子而已
卖完没有迭景 就是要谈
这就是一个停损哥的红包所以呢这个处置教育真的很有趣很有趣最近做处置
其实以前做的没有那么
以前我做的没有那么多
我最近做的特别大
为什么做的特别大
因为这软体太好用了
因为这软体因为我一直就想说
那我要用的话
我要找一个
我要把这个界面把它写好一点
跟各位讲我用的最多
好不好
这软体我用的最多
我買的分點是全國第一名
買分點是全國第一名
我剛跟你講的股票 我買的分點是全國第一名
我買的是全國最多的
他的訊號出來 我買的股票是全國最多的
那你還不相信他 就不要信
賣信
賣妹
就這樣子
好啦 那今天的直播快閃呢
這個進階版是45,000
但是重點 因為他有每個月的實戰陪跑
所以呢 我們每個月都會錄影
就像那個PG錄影
我們會把那個細節講細一點
那其實我是覺得這重要
這邊重要的是你要去學這些細節
然後軟體它最近做的特別
我是覺得它盯得很緊
所以它每次的處置的預測越來越準確
像今天聯發科一堆預測它3600會進處置
結果今天聯發科根本沒有進處置
那這個就是我們一直在優化它
一直誘化它
那這後面有個重點是雙刀戰法
雙刀戰法是說
例如說
那個我在買建測的時候
我害怕怎麼樣
我害怕我買了之後
那假如整個
那個三二族群還是崩跌
那怎麼辦
所以呢我買建測之後呢
我就做了一個交易
就是我去空旗紅
那我在趙華節目我特別講
建測旗紅比是多少
那各位你去算一下
建策其永比就如我们预期般的往上走了
为什么很简单吧
因为昨天其永涨4%
它没有涨停嘛
昨天建策涨停
所以建策其永比就如我们预期往上走
那这个比值呢
我觉得后面往上走的机率还是蛮高的
那不过建策明天被关了
明天被关
明天被关了之后
那个现象会有点改变
假如建策又大跌
然后其永没什么跌
这个又可以开始做
反正呢这个交易呢
很有意思的
我们最近用这个处置用双刀做了很多交易
但是台面上呢我们就不要讲太多
因为这些都是那个进阶处置策略
那儲制呢
就跟各位講儲制就是你去研究儲制的事件
那這個在基礎儲制會教
然後呢
最好的策略就是
拉回找買點
浪子回頭找買點
就這樣而已
非常簡單
儲就這樣子
那這些都是儲制
上過儲制課的一些學員的
新的分享
那我們的500人群組到目前為止還是499
已經過了一兩個月了
過你兩個月
好啦,這是儲治的狀況
儲治狀況是這樣子的
儲治這個,這個很多人賺很多啦
好,那儲治呢,他有儲治日報
準確度非常高
這個越來越準了
然後呢,還有儲治股的監控
那儲治神器呢,還可以幫助你
這邊,可以讓你看一下獨家統計
來,我給各位,再看一次統計啦
因為這統計呢
先給各位了解一下
儲治股的大概狀況
因為統計是這樣子的
來來來 我們來張圖給各位看
處置呢 在第一天呢 會比較弱
後面平均來講比較強
後面平均來講是比較強的
那這是全樣本 那假如五分樣本的話呢
在初關那一天平均來講比較弱
所以很多人都問我說 為什麼初關變弱了
那我就想 那大概率是五分中的股票
它就會比較弱
比較弱 那這個
這個假如有跌回來都是讓你找買點
因為後面都蠻強的
那這種統計呢
這種統計的數字呢
它會隨著大盤偏多偏空的會有點改變
所以呢你的策略呢
就可以從這邊來做個微調
我們都是用
用統計用科技來做股票
不是用情感來下單好不好
你用情感來下單
你就去買00403A
好不好
因為你的情感
你就喜歡買10塊錢的股票
那買10塊錢的股票
買10塊錢的股票真的是
你就是10块钱便宜
我说便宜跟贵不是这样看的 好不好
便宜跟贵不是这样看的
你喜欢买便宜的股票
你现在银件股一堆都很便宜
一堆都很便宜
便宜跟贵不是这样看的 好不好
好
比较好奇小哥赚这么多
还会想出一堆东西照顾大宗
你这个想法 你就这样子
就像我们
我们为什么学员
这个
开了火锅店我们天天去吃因为呢 我们就是想吃好吃的东西好吃的東西跟各位分享然後要想吃健康的東西嘛那為什麼我們天天去 我今天又去吃了
為什麼今天這個又去吃
欸 給我看看 因為 因為它就健康嘛
你自己看 它就是健康的火鍋啊
你自己看這些食材
那整個都是 整個都是那個
圓形食物吧
健康的東西嘛
啊素食吃豆包嘛
豆包豆腐嘛 玉米嘛 都是
都是原型食物嘛 健康嘛
你說啊 賺那麼多啊就
自己賺就好了 幹嘛講
我跟各位講
啊幹嘛講 我現在跟你講00403億價過高
我明天去空他
我講完之後 他價格只會變低 不會變高
好不好 那為什麼要講 我們就是喜歡講啊
我們就是喜歡
我們就是有正義感嘛 喜歡講嘛
我們喜歡把好的東西分享嘛
所以你看很多學員跟我變成朋友嘛
學員變成朋友 你一乘幾何時
你去看到有人這樣子
找一堆學員來聚餐
然後大家吃得很開心嗎
當然是有啦
但是我相信
我相信 我相信
台股的
某些
某些比較惡劣的齁 就是
每次明明沒有這檔股票
然後漲了就說他有這檔股票的一些投股老師
他敢開這種趴
我們講的是比較惡劣的
比較惡劣 你敢開這種趴 你敢嗎
你敢開這種趴 開的時候呢
我一串人去很生氣 說老師為什麼
為什麼他有買我沒買
為什麼你說股票漲停買 為什麼他都有
為什麼我沒有
你是初級會員 你去做角落
对不对
可以这样子吗
我们当然是
都是教学员比较
那个好的交易模式
会赚钱的交易模式
所以这群人才会从
全台各地
台东 屏东 高雄
一堆来这里聚会
来这里聚会
然后来这边跟我聊天
我们教完都不怕
跟那个学员见面的
不怕
怕什么
我又没害他
我害他我才要怕
我每天坑殺他我才要怕嘛 對不對
我講每天那個講一些股票
然後高檔出貨股然後叫他去買
這個我才要害怕嘛
啊我又沒做這種事情我怕什麼你懂嗎我沒做這種事情我我怕什麼 你懂嗎我沒做這種事情 我怕什麼 你懂嗎講太多上禮拜 隔天被添 盯上就盯上 怕什麼
建設 被黃仁勳盯上了
黃仁勳看到我直播 講了他壞話
怕什麼 我還是賺錢啊
你懂嗎 我還是賺錢 我根本不用怕
好
好 那處置神器呢
可以看得出來個股進處置第幾天
當然看得出來喔
齁 來啦 這邊啦 來來來
當然看得出來
來 來喔
這裡喔 這裡啊 你看
像今天呢 剛被關的 具有嘛
被關是不是就跌 核金被關跌 環球金被關跌嘛
建村被關跌
川寶被關跌兩天
那我就買了嘛
那林桶比較強 被關長兩天
你看大部分第一天還是跌嘛
那就是第一天被關的
那明天被關的有明輝 聯軍 川武 忠祐
那這些是被關的
明天被關的 5月13號開始 這些被關
5月12號開始被關的
5月11號開始被關的有這些
這邊都可以看得出來
他被關之後 後面的走勢
後面走勢都看得出來
聯發科 聯發科被關的第一天落後面很強
所以聯發科這很強啦
連發課問我說
連發課拉回都是讓你找買點的
你懂嗎
拉回都讓你找買點的
所以這個
如果處置股去的話
千萬別修啊
好不好
修什麼處置股法律
我勸這些主管機關
稍管閒事
不要管處置好不好
該關就關
好不好
真的很好
哇有人講
五月做處置六三六勝
讚
讚啊
只有三萬不能投自己財嗎
當然可以啊
當然可以投資理財啊
你可以買零股啊
你懂嗎 有一堆零股可以買嘛
當然可以啊
可以的 沒問題的 買零股可以啊
你去研究
研究事件買零股 OK嗎
我們都是教各位怎麼做股票的方法
所以呢
你買零股就好了嘛 對不對
連發顆零股也可以買啊 對不對
連發顆零股也才三四千塊而已啊
當然可以買
建設當然做啦 對不對
好 所以這個可以玩零股啦
好啦 那處置神秘就這樣子喔
那今天這個因為有web版的關係啊所以呢我們再看一次這個處置的們再看一次儲惠各位有需要的可以購買
那最近是做儲置股很好做的時期
那這個常常在大盤的
就是很瘋狂的
瘋狂大漲的時期會遇到
所以跟各位講
你不要等到盤變空了
鏡空的那個儲置股票就會變少
那時候就可惜了 那時候我就不會推了
因為他說沒什麼儲置股
我們就不會推儲置神器了
就不會推了
所以呢這個上次進去早賣了好不好
喔
兩個月70萬賺17萬32%
謝謝小哥 恭喜你 恭喜你
所以等到儲置股沒什麼標的的時候
我們也不會推了
因為趁現在很好做 趕快做
我做的量是全台灣數一數二的大
好不好 我們買的點位
張數 很多人都看得到
都看得到
看得到
都很好用
這軟體就是
這個我在用的啦
好啦
來 這是這個處置的
欸 我們這今天新的還沒講
新的還沒講
好啦 新的喔
來 小哥是有故事的人
最近見稱逆轉勝故事太精彩
這個一定有訂閱PP
喔 訂PP太超值啦
台股平創高的時間點 依舊能挑出經濟微影大力光這些機器
大力光 喔 大力光我今天爽了好不好
今天大力光 各位 突然想到我的大力光
喔 今天大力光開心了好不好 各位
三多哥啊 欸 三多哥一日逆轉啊
有沒有 三多哥是不是一日逆轉
你以為了解他賠錢的時候你不賠
浪子回頭你不賠
他也像浪子回頭嘛
對 東山再起你是誰
有沒有看到
東山再起你是誰 浪子回頭
浪子回頭
只是他沒被處置而已啊
三多顆賠一兩億的時候你不賠
對不對 你不賠
然後呢
你就要等到
等到要漲停 問
欸小哥可以追嗎
我不知道我可不可以追
當然追高點風險有限啊
追高點比較有風險 不是風險有限
追高點就是有風險
不是風險有限
然後呢這個大力光吼他是有古奇可以做的喔
他是有古奇可以做的
他有小古奇小大力光
啊
來各位小大力光
古奇要學起來
學起來
小大力光保證金還38000
好不好各位
你剛有說3萬塊的
那個
再去存一點錢你就可以買小大力光了
今天早上的時候他才35000
保證金才35000
然後今天漲了255塊
255塊是什麼意思呢
就是25500
保證金35000
然後呢今天漲了25500
所以剛剛有3萬塊的
多存5000塊保證金
你就可以來買小麗光了
買小麗光今天讓你賺了25500
因為這小麗光是一口一百股
一口一百股
所以你看35000也可以玩啊
你懂嗎
3萬5也可以玩嘛
所以你可以用3萬5
來買這些小型的嘛
而且保證金有的都很便宜啊
你看這邊很便宜啊
喔
排序一下
哇還有1320的
怎麼便宜成這樣
喔 彩晶2800
喔 2800也可以做啊
2800今天漲了多少
今天這個彩晶漲了10
漲了...欸...漲了多少錢
這個...
他今天...
漲了0.95
0.95呢就是...
漲了1900塊
保證金2800
今天漲了1900塊
就這樣
這個...
古期就這樣買
你的保證金這邊都看得到
這保證金一兩千的很多啦
這個幾千的很多
應該說幾...一萬以內很多
很多
啊這些投資呢
你要抓好時間點
假如這些股票有進儲置的話
哇那可以好好的玩
可以好好玩
來玩這些進儲置的股票
那進儲置之前
他有可能比較弱
那進儲置之後他有機會轉強
那這些都可以用期貨來做
都可以用期貨來做
那我們這個
期貨也可以用來做避險
那也可以拿來做套利
我們這邊就好了 架材套利 來來這裡我今天這裡來來這邊買齊套利 今天支援就可以套但是尾盤尾盤你要怎麼套
你要去空股票買支援期
支援期我你買得到
但空股票不一定空得到
我今天我有空股票 我有空到
那我就來套
但是那個贓助就沒辦法
沒辦法很
很很抓得很準了啦
反正這些呢 有很多都可以套
这套利一套2.7%
像新唐也可以套 各位看一下
新唐 买股棋是176
股票可以空180.5
那你空盘后可以空181
盘后空181
这也是可以套
这个棋卧跟现卧它有很多种玩法
你可以赌单边 有钱一点可以做套利
我们最近我们那个
我们的这个聊天群里面
一堆在做套利
我做了一堆套利
建策我也套翻
因為建策它這個期貨跟套利
期貨跟現貨可以套利100塊
100塊 這很香
那咬覺得說
小哥你講這個都太難
我們用一個方法
用台積電的股票期貨
它可以讓你創造
假如最近的狀況沒變
假如沒變的話
台積電股票期貨可以讓你創造
1年10%報酬
無論台積電漲還是跌
這個厲害了吧
再講一次喔
台積電的股票期貨跟股票
合起來可以讓你創造一年10%的報酬
10%
無論台積電漲還是跌
欸這個 這很
很多人不知道為什麼
有的人是股票漲了就賺錢
有的人是股票跌了才賺錢
我們是無論漲還是跌 不管
只要台積電呢
目前的狀態沒變的話
一年可以賺10%
那這些呢
每年每個月只要做一個動作
一年做12个动作结束一年赚10%
然后没什么风险
为什么你有多有空
要怎么创造
欢迎来上古奇课
好 古奇课呢就会教你
因为最近那个
不过古奇课快满了
台中厂已满
台北厂也快满了
各位你只有
影音听一听的好不好
影音听一听
因为我们只开三场
反正没听到就听影音
好啦
一路人叫我录屁屁
好啦 我们今天讲到这边
這裡啊
小哥的處置神器太香了一直宣誓小哥去說下去通過處置翻證人真的很多當中不了來用處置真的很好不過還是有點小心才會好做 因為為什麼 因為
他那個 他要隔日啦 他不像當衝
但是當衝 太懶了 好不好 太懶了
好好學處置啦
喔
當小哥學人很幸福 小哥無視分享自己賺錢方式
讓學人來吞噬他的獲利 我覺得沒差啦 沒差
你吞就吞 我們就是
這沒差 大家賺錢開心就好
很好看到小哥老師能夠超完自裸
有穩定獲利出來教課的
從短線地板股、處置股到低檔的
長線的低檔關鍵買殼轉載
每招都在股市
每招都是在股市必學的招數
而且PB還每天更新新股回復學的問題
那感謝小哥學教學
這禮拜我真是希望能抽到生理物啊
可以可以沒有問題
好
清風大為我就送你娃娃啦
好啦恭喜祝生日快樂
好
好啦
那我們今天呢就講的差不多講到這裡啦
講到這邊
那各位呢有需要購買的
在這邊
這邊有處置神器的購買連結
然後呢討論區連結的是4個8
4個8
這個詐騙不要來
詐騙不要來
4個8
好
那我們最後呢
欸等一下
我們再來講一下
那明天有一堂課是高配級重買攻略
這在明天5月13日
這有實體場
實際上目前還有位置
有需要的也可以去
那股價休業實戰班呢
台中已滿 高雄沒滿 台北快滿了
然後呢 籌碼K線
13個月呢 送443檔 關鍵分點
那交易筆記本
這個每天都有交易心得在裡面啦
就是
我們那時候建設講的非常多
講非常多
那我跟各位講我會怎麼做
我都預告在前面 好不好
預告在前面
重點就是要預告在前面嘛
你說在後面沒什麼用
就像我們建設我們在
上禮拜理財團就有講得很清楚
他就是這禮拜就是會談啦
他就會談
但明天被關20分鐘
我希望20分鐘再跌下來
再跌下來可能又會出現一個
很好的買點
我希望20分鐘的建設
跌下來讓我買
或者我可以來做個雙刀
好啦 最後
喜歡今天直播歡迎按讚訂閱
留言關心的
歡迎各位按個讚訂閱我一下好不好
訂閱我一下
目前已經快到
快到9萬人
還差1萬人
我們最後呢抽景品娃娃
喔台中台北都滿了
不好意思台中台北都滿了
好啦那處理成績欸分期喔再找機會跟小民族聊一下下好 看有沒有機會來 這抽幾毛毛軟體喔這個現場QA時間 不要走開
後面有抽獎
好 來吧
股票 期貨 實戰課 台中廠是幾號上課
幾號上課
這禮拜五
這禮拜五上課
這禮拜五上課喔
好 然後我們來抽一下
抽一下
這個亂術產生劑這裡
哇 又是飯店
知道我很久沒出國了
哎呀 已經
幾十天沒出國了
甚是想念 哎呦仙台
都知道我想去掀台
好啦 5號 10號
恭喜5號 10號中獎啦
好啦
最後
這個有沒有什麼問題啊
反正
有問題都可以來批批問啊
我們都會回答
這個處置呢很好用
就讓子回頭早買一點
再跟各位講一次
他就很簡單的策略啊
對初學者而言讓子回頭早買一點
對進階者而言
讓主持有找慢一點
東山再起就找慢一點
東山再起跟那個
這個初見有漲10%都是
東山再起跟
跟那個
來看一下
這邊有個儲置回檔後漲10%
都是漲10%以上
所以這邊有很多漲10%以上
東山再起
這裡有很多東山再起
儲置回檔之後
後面就東山再起
所以呢
用這些訊號來找股票
買了希望他冬山債起
就這樣而已 很簡單
然後呢 進階者呢
我們就可以來玩雙刀
那雙刀呢就是 一多一空
那詳細的雙刀策略呢
為了保護使用者權益
我們在這裡就不要講太多
那各位呢 這個影音裡面都有講
各位可以去影音裡面看
好啦 那我們今天的直播就講到這邊了
各位記得明天0403A
千萬不要亂追好不好 千萬不要亂追
只要我可以申購到
我一定空爆它
哈哈
再跟各位講一次
只要我可以
申購到
我一定
空爆它
再給你看一次
我的那個
我的
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕